In today's video,
we're taking a look
at the difference
between full batteries
and batteries that have been
drained of all of their juices.
How are they different?
And how can you easily
tell them apart?
[Music]
We've got a bunch of batteries.
So far, these batteries are
in good condition,
but we want to do
some tests to see
what's different between
a fully charged battery,
and it fully drained battery.
And we want to see
if we can figure out
how you can tell the difference
between the two.
Here's the basic idea.
We have seen
that you can bounce
batteries to tell
whether or not they are charged.
So we're going to try that,
see what's different,
and then try a few
other tests as well.
First step is we need
to drain power out of these.
So I've got a flashlight.
When I bought it
on the packaging,
it said that it gave like
two and a half hours of light.
So I figured we can put
the battery in there,
see how dim the flashlight gets,
and then take it out,
and see how much worse it is.
After that, we're going
to put batteries
in for progressively smaller
increments of time to see
if we can get a perfect scale
of a fully charged battery
to a fully dead battery, and see
what the differences are.
So we've got batteries
in this flashlight, and now,
what we want to do is just let
it sit for a long time.
We want to drain all of the
power out of these batteries.
All right, we have
now taken batteries,
and we have drained them a lot.
We actually had one set
of batteries we left in
overnight to really try
and drain them off,
and that wasn't even
necessarily quite enough.
So we then took those batteries,
and we put them
into a remote control car,
and left it running to try
and drain them even more.
Other than that,
we have batteries
at 15 minute increments
from 2 hours and 15 minutes
all the way down to none.
So first thing,
I want to try that bounce test.
Everybody says that you
can bounce the batteries,
and a perfectly charged battery
isn't going to bounce,
and the one that's pretty close
to empty is going to have
a lot more bounce to it.
First thing I want to do is just
holding it over the counter,
and dropping it,
the same way anyone would
if they're pulling batteries
out of a junk drawer,
and they're not sure, like,
oh, is this good battery?
Is it a bad battery?
This is supposed to be
the super easy way to test.
If this works at all,
I want to scale it up,
and have just a whole setup
that will drop all
of the batteries at once,
from fully charged
to completely drained,
and see if we can get
them to just bounce
in a nice little array.
But first, let's try
the "I just found the battery
in a junk drawer" test.
[Music]
So the one at 2 hours
and 15 minutes,
quite a bit of bounce to it.
But the one
that's fully charged.
It's like the one ring.
There's no bounce.
Editors, can we put in the clip
of the One Ring hitting
the ground, please?
So, I want to know
if there's a weight difference.
They don't feel
any different to me.
But that doesn't mean
that it's not there.
As far as I can tell
just holding them,
they feel the same.
I'm just trying to see
like is there any slight bowing,
or change in like
how flat any parts of it are.
I really am
not seeing anything,
so I don't think that's changed.
I think that's intentional.
They don't want
the battery to distort
as you use it.
We have a very sensitive scale.
This thing is designed
for measuring gunpowder,
and we've got it set
to grams right now.
So let's do a test.
All right, let's get one
of our fully charged batteries.
Here we go.
It's fully charged?
Fully charged.
>> No marks on it.
>> Alright.
24.4.
[Music]
24.45.
24.25.
So we do have a little bit
of variation here.
Amost all of these batteries
are from one package.
They all came together,
and you can see
that they actually say
USA printed on top.
Yeah.
These two batteries came
with the flashlight,
and they do not have USA printed
to the top of them.
So they are slightly
different in some way.
So this is the one
that we just tried
the bounce test with.
This is at 2 hours
15 minutes of use.
24.25.
Now, that would be exactly
the same as the full battery
from this same batch.
That's true.
Also 2 hours
and 15 minutes,
just the other one.
24.35.
Still very much
within the same range.
Yeah, grab a one in the middle,
and see which--
30 minutes.
[Music]
24.4.
So I'm going to say the weight,
and I didn't think the weight
it was going to change.
Nothing is escaping.
Nothing is leaving the battery
as you're using it.
And so, the mass is the same,
it's not going
to be any different.
Even though I was pretty sure
that was the case,
I did want to test.
Because maybe
something was escaping.
But it seems
that the mass is unchanged.
We've now had
these three batteries
running our remote-control car
for a little bit
after they ran the flashlight
for a long time.
So these two batteries were
in the flashlight overnight,
and then to really try
and drain them the rest the way,
we threw them into
this remote control car.
We drove that around.
0% batteries versus full battery.
We've already done bounce tests,
and we've seen that our full
battery will not bounce,
whereas our empty battery will.
[Music]
Not bad.
So empty, also empty, full.
Let's take our voltmeter.
and test it
on the batteries to see
how much power each
of these have.
First off, a full battery.
Okay, we are getting a reading
of 1.6 volts, almost exactly.
Just a hair over.
1.6 volts.
Now, our drain batteries.
This is as dead
as we can get it.
[Music]
We are looking at 0.0981.
So that's not zero.
It's not showing
that there's no power
left in this battery.
But in the RC car,
this wasn't working anymore.
So a dead battery actually
still has over half
of what a battery has initially.
In terms of voltage, at least.
Yeah.
Now, how well
that translates into usable
power probably depends
on what device you're using.
If I put these two dead
batteries in our flashlights,
we're still getting light
out of the flashlight.
So it's not a hundred
percent drained clearly,
but in something
like the RC car, it needs
a little bit more power.
Especially if the wheels
are actually in contact
with the ground,
it can barely overcome the
coefficient of static friction
to get this thing moving.
For the most part,
it just like limps along
at a quarter of a mile an hour.
Whereas with full batteries,
it actually kind of zooms
around a little bit.
Full battery, 1.6-ish volts.
Empty battery, 0.98 volts.
There's one that was
in the flashlight
for only 15 minutes.
1.476.
That's a quick drop off.
Yeah, I would not have
expected that much--
Even in 15 minutes,
it goes from 1.6 to 1.47.
Like that just...
We tried weighing the batteries,
and now, we've
used a voltmeter.
And we can definitely tell
with the voltmeter
what's a good fresh battery,
and what's been used.
And it drops off pretty quick.
I was surprised at how fast.
So, after 15 minutes,
you can already see
that you've got
a 0.2 drop in it.
That's kind of insane
given the fact that
at the end of running
something in a car
until it would no longer
go anywhere, it was 0.98.
It's clearly not a linear scale
for using the voltage
in a battery.
It drops off very
quickly at first,
and then levels out quite a bit.
We had to run these batteries
for a long time to get
them below 1 volt.
We've got some Masonite,
we got a board,
and we've got some strips.
We are just going to glue
all these strips on,
at least one battery wide,
and then have just
sort of a rail system.
And all of these batteries
will just fall down
next to each other,
and we get a good shot, a test,
the batteries in line
from a completely
charged battery to completely
discharged battery.
[Music]
Here's our battery track.
In theory, we should be able
to take a battery,
and drop it.
It worked. It dropped.
Fell all the way down
with pretty much no resistance,
that's the goal right there.
[Music]
We've got our battery
rail box set up,
and hopefully,
the automatic drop system
all works smoothly.
Let's give this a test.
Our batteries are currently
in line from fully charged
to very much depleted.
3, 2, 1.
[Music]
That was cool.
It was cool.
They didn't all hit
the ground at the same time.
It didn't.
That's really cool.
Yeah, that looks...
That looks good.
Like once we can actually get
it to go on the right speed.
I think it's going to work.
I think so.
[Music]
We are having just a little bit
of trouble getting all
the batteries to drop
at the same time.
I think they're sticking
a little bit to the paint.
And so we actually just added
some corn starch on the inside,
to sort of a dry
lubricant, and...
It's going to be
a little powdery,
but I think it's going
to work a little bit better.
Yeah, this should be good.
All right.
3, 2, 1.
[Music]
From a higher spot this time.
Oh, no.
3, 2, 1.
[Music]
Look, it kike hits it.
That's it.
No-- Oh, one of them fully
jumped up out of the frame.
[Music]
Guys, it's not all.
We've always got more
for you to see.
That box up at the top is going
to take you to our last video.
You should go check that out.
The other box
is going to show you
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
And if you hit this bomb
here in the middle,
you'll be subscribe
to the channel,
and that way, you're never going
to miss a cool video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we will see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.